Aaron's in his new memoir the 17
traditions this talk from the bagdad
theater in Portland Oregon is about 45
minutes good evening thanks for coming
out tonight on behalf of powell's books
I'd like to welcome you to the
Macmillan's back forgive the
pronunciation bagdad theater I'd like to
thank the Baghdad and its staff for
being so great to work with we're really
fortunate to have such a splendid venue
as this in which to hold events so once
again thank you Baghdad few persons have
given up themselves for the sake of
their fellows as tirelessly as has Ralph
Nader for nigh on five decades Ralph has
worked unceasingly on a broad range of
issues and causes fighting corruption
and promoting positive human and
environmental values tonight Ralph will
discuss his new book the 17 traditions
this book focuses on the family the
values and traditions that make families
strong and the value of strong families
for their members for their communities
and for the world with mothers and
fathers day coming the 17 traditions
would make a wonderful gift for a parent
as a would for any family member or
friend ladies and gentlemen Ralph Nader
ok
thank you
thank you very much thank you Scott and
Greg thank you all for coming having
trouble seeing you but I've never
written a book like this before and I
want to explain why I wrote it in
addition to being a love story or my mom
and dad and my sisters and brother I
wrote it because if you are looking for
active citizens to help you and making a
better country or community after a
while you run out of exhortations and
you ask yourself how can we get more
active citizens and sometimes you have a
demonstration you have a march people
come they connect or somebody has a
tragedy and form something like Mothers
Against Drunk Driving or they might come
out of the university's perchance having
some sort of mission whether in science
engineering politics economics
organizing whatever but it's never
enough they're never enough active
citizens and if you look at the
generation of citizens who are active
from the get-go you go back to the
family you have to recognize in many
ways that the family has become a
political football extreme right-wing
people like to espouse family values
we've seen how that's played out and the
family is under great pressure it's the
primordial unit of any society any
culture in history of the world and it
is under tremendous pressure because of
economic pressure the separation hour
after hour from the parents and the
children long commutes it's under
commercial pressure or in the first
generation of systemic direct commercial
marketing to little children by passing
their parents and undermining parental
authority and getting these children to
systematically nag their parents and to
be exposed to pretty rotten things like
violent programming violent toys and
junk food / medication the third type of
pressure is a low expectation by the
society at large which gives lot at loud
lip service to children you know
children first but our children are
terribly mistreated in our society and
not just child abuse and not just or
juvenile detention centers are like
they're mistreated in there not even
given universal health coverage they're
not given adequate and quality day care
there's not enough arm around the
shoulder they are exposed to fast food
companies that sell them products and
lure them into their stores that are
going to give them serious illnesses
often lawler children diabetes later
high blood pressure they're exposed to
the most violent personal programming in
the history of the world now they're
exposed to an opportunity to be
interactive and engage in tearing limbs
to shreds through these activities of
what I call these corporate electronic
child molesters and
and so it's time to be very
self-conscious about families it's time
to tap into traditions when the family
was more intact and more together the
extended family and to derive from each
family's background the best insights
wisdom and experience and retain it and
record it and jot it down and pass it on
to the next generation it's not just
that children have never meant to have
to reinvent the wheel it's that they may
have difficulty reinventing any wheel if
they spend their childhood 50 hours a
week watching screens computer screens
television screens video game screens
estranged from nature and their natural
surroundings not having an opportunity
to socialize themselves with other human
beings including members of their family
shortening or vocabulary and their
attention span so I'm trying to give a
context is very personal book because
I'd like to see a broadening tradition
of putting down family traditions family
by family the quality of the world is
traced to the quality of parental
upbringing there have been enough
studies showing that the battered child
grows up to be the battering parent
there's enough studies to show where
dictators come from and while there are
many other environmental and social
factors that shape people's character
and personality it's quite clear that
the parental environment is probably the
most important Heraclitus the ancient
philosopher once said character is
destiny and I would add personality is
decisive and the development of
character and person
he comes first and foremost as
Montessori and others have showed us
from the early years and their parental
experiences and upbringing when I asked
active citizens as I always like to how
did you become active sometimes
tragedies sometimes alienation against
their parents if their parents are
corporate executives for example
sometimes they have a labor union
tradition but more often than not here
are the answers why are you active when
I meet these confident steady refreshing
figures I like to ask them how they
became the people they are how they
developed such drive such motivation and
purpose quite often they hesitate then
they smile and respond well when I was
young my parents my mother my father my
teacher my neighbor told me took me
showed me inspired me for democracy
cannot flourish without putting an arm
around the shoulders of the young that's
one of the reasons I wrote this little
book and in so doing I had to answer
that question to report it and to
Senator Bobby Kennedy at the celebrated
hearings on gm's detective caper at the
US Senate in 1966 when he leaned forward
and he said why are you doing this this
meaning why have you spent time trying
to get cars that are crashworthy and
save lives I said to home you know if I
was engaged in an effort to prevent
cruelty to animals I wouldn't be asked
that question
but because I was engaged in trying to
prevent cruelty to humans I'm constantly
asked that question and so is my mother
she would get calls from reporters what
did he eat how did you raise him was he
a rebel from the start how can you
explain what he's doing he went to
Princeton at harvard law school he
should be now in a corporate law firm
instead he hitchhiked to Washington from
Connecticut to get congressional
committees interested in investigating
the auto companies which were never then
subject to two federal safety standards
well she got a little weary of this and
one day a reporter called out and said
mrs. Nader what makes Ralph tick and she
retorted what makes you not tick
and that's my parents that they didn't
think that being an active citizen was a
deviation they thought it was a natural
thing to do that civic activity in the
community was an extension of Family
Values Family Values neighborhood values
community values national values world
values and so they were always
astonished and I was astonished because
they would take their children to the
town meetings I'll get to the city the
landscape in a moment but we grew up in
a 10,000 people town a very contentious
factory town and northwest connecticut
nestled in the litchfield hills lot of
lakes rivers streams meadows woods and
my parents would take me and my two
sisters and brother they take me to the
town meetings it was a town meeting
former government and the people were
the legislature you couldn't have a more
pristine form of democracy and there'd
be maybe 200 people there in the
auditorium to 50 or so and it'd be like
seven people standing up and it would be
often the same seven people and it would
challenge the mayor and it would have
the information and they would ask
questions and the other people in the
audience would look at them like yeah go
on the other hand but they're so they're
so officious you know they're so pushy
there's a sort of mixed feeling the next
day walking down our long Main Street
one of the citizens name was mr. friends
you know people would say there goes mr.
friends and here i'm watching this it's
like there's a town fool a town drunk
and a town citizen
and instead of someone saying there goes
mr. Jones he doesn't give a hoot about
the community in ancient Greece the word
idiot had nothing to do with lack of
intelligence the word idiot meant a
person who is apathetic about his or her
community didn't do anything to improve
it one who didn't play out the Athenian
code of citizenship which was to
paraphrase it I pledged to leave Athens
better than I entered it well this town
Winston was the most contentious town
i've ever been in it was split right
down the middle Republican Democrat Red
Sox fans Yankee fans had two rivers one
was called the Mad River the others
called the still river in nineteen
hundred a hundred small factories and
fabrication plants show you what towns
used to produce in those days there
almost all gone and the rivers were
sewers chemical sewers for the factories
they dump dies in there they dumped all
kinds of heavy metals and so the town
said well you know you can't get much
worse so they dump the sewage there
untreated and we never grew up with
those rivers they didn't mean anything
to us any natural splendor we couldn't
wait in him we couldn't fish in them we
couldn't have lunch on their banks they
were industrial sewers however there was
other kinds of beauty and into town and
within 20 minutes walk you had the lakes
the streams the meadows the woods the
firehouse police station the stores the
schools the library the hospital the
doctor a dentist the town hall the
railroad station with seven trains to
New York 120 miles away per day and that
is a great place to grow up that kind of
accessibility wonderful
we walked to school up to a mile through
snowdrifts they enclose the schools when
there is a dusty as they do in
Washington DC and and we didn't have
weather updates every two seconds as
well it's that's that's the the setting
and I start this book not with the 17
traditions which were 17 ways my mom and
dad raised us but with my connection
with certain natural artifacts that I
started reflecting on only a few years
ago and was really amazed how important
they were to me first the giant maple
tree in front of my bedroom it was like
a menagerie squirrels Birds howling
winds autumn leaves fluttering to the
ground the snow would cling to the
branches and the twigs and beautiful and
when I got old enough I climbed the tree
and climbed higher and higher in the
tree then there was the boulder the
four-foot boulder at the civil war
monument which was about 65 feet high
commemorating the soldiers who fought a
civil war those who died and that
Boulder was a world for me as a little
boy I hugged it I looked at the insects
as they went into the crevices I flew
kites from it it was a whole world was
my friend my mother would give me a
sandwich and I'd run up and sit on on it
look at the stars and there were woods
near meadows there were a lot of
wonderful natural surroundings that we
communicated with and years later I
written in New York Times that there was
a program for kids from Harlem to go
during the summer and spend a couple
weeks with a rural family and how how
strange the kids felt it was the first
time in their life that they had put
their feet on soil and
thought it was dirty because their whole
lives was on cement and asphalt what are
we losing when millions of children
today look at screens hour after hour
after hour what are we losing just
because we can't quantify it I think if
we become more self-conscious about this
we'll find out more of what we're losing
let me just start with the some of the
traditions I want to give you a flavor
of of the family my parents came to to
the United States when here 19 years old
it was a new culture new language and
they had to learn it and they learned it
in part from their children they had a
tradition reciprocity their children of
course immediately born here were new
the culture although fads and all the
things that were rather strange and so
they taught the parents and the parents
integrated it in terms of their own
framework ethical and advisory framework
and a tradition of reciprocity never
left us parents taught us we informed
taught our parents however they were
obviously a few steps ahead of us and my
mother once very early said to us if you
talk all the time you're not going to
learn anything so the first tradition is
learn to listen learn to listen
something that held me in good stead
when I hitchhiked tens and tens of
thousands of miles later on and listened
to the person behind the wheel who is
always an expert in something a tree
surgeon a builder whatever tradition of
learning to listen help and because also
when we went to town meetings that we
went to gatherings we weren't Restless
we weren't fidgeting
because we've learned to listen and
therefore observed a great deal we
didn't dominate guests and my parents at
dinner at a dinner table we were
listening and listening doesn't mean you
never talk obviously it just means that
you think more before you talk the
tradition of the family table part of it
is that we didn't fidget about food we
were told at an early age you don't know
what you want because you don't know
enough to know what you want and my
mother said that will eat what they eat
Nelly we know double standard and so it
was over but then it wasn't oh he's over
and I would for example say I don't like
this and it'd be a radishes or maybe
turnips I don't like this and my mother
would say too bad eat it and sometimes I
I'd be emphatic and I said I don't like
this and she'd lean down look at me and
she say who's I and I said I Ralph I'm
your son no no you said I don't like
this who's I is I your heart your
kidneys your lungs is I your brain I'm
more puzzled than ever at this point
and she's I think I know who I is
because these this food is very good for
your heart and your lungs and your
kidneys and your liver and your brain I
know who i is i is your tongue and
you're turning it against your brain eda
she said with her dazzling smile health
how do you get a child to listen to a
mother and father about taking care of
their health when they come down with
chicken pox whooping cough and measles
they are very attentive and that's when
she gently advised us how to take care
of our our health history tradition of
history we'd run home from school at
lunchtime and she would unveil another
chapter in some historical saga now she
had a tremendous memory as did my dad
because they grew up before electricity
came to their area in Lebanon and they
had to have a good memory they had to
remember proverbs they had to remember
sagas they had to remember their family
history going back four or five
generations they had to learn about
their community history they had to
learn about when something happened and
when something didn't happen and as a
result we really grew up steeped in
history and they'd have ways to drive at
home they would say how much would you
know about yourself if all you knew was
your last six months made her very
personal and occurred to me that if my
mother was raising little Georgie w bush
with a tradition of listening and
history we would not be in Iraq today
the tradition scarcity they didn't
overload us with toys and things and
things and things we wouldn't value them
when the time came for dad to give me a
first base meant that lasted for 10
years he didn't say well now it's time
for second basement her koechers met and
so we tended to develop a tradition of
thrift and during world war two you know
things were rationed so we had a victory
garden like a lot of people in our
country and we also put the thermostat
down and we wore a sweater and we saved
on fuel and gasoline was rationed and so
from that came to the effort on energy
conservation it just came out very
naturally in terms of looking at the
enormous waste in our economy staggering
waste of food and fuel and wood and raw
materials and you name it we were rooted
in that tradition it stayed with us it
didn't leave us when we went to college
our parents never preferred one child
over another nutrition tradition of
sibling equality because we all know
that it's a devastating impact on a
disfavored child that can last a
lifetime I don't know any more
predictable devastating internal
household impact other than physical
child abuse then preferring consistently
some children over another and we would
Beit my mother to try to get her you
somewhat you know and try to just you
know lay a trap for you know like so
well clearly my older sister it's
behaving so much better and it's so
smarter as she would never became a
family joke another family joke was
she'd have a nice birthday cake for us
with all kinds of frosting and we'd blow
out the candles and with a smile she'd
carefully skim off the frosting
off it would go and this got the
attention years later the wall street
journal who actually devoted an
editorial denounced seen my mother for
her puritanical ways and of course it
was a family joke and the thing that got
the wall street journal i guess they got
tired of slamming me and fifty editorial
said to take out my mother was she she
gave us raw chickpeas to chew on on the
way to school and that was for the wall
street journal the final straw i guess
they preferred eminem's then there's a
tradition of education and argument and
this was at least to say were educated
at home and we were instructed in school
we had fairly good teachers as teachers
go but when i came home one day at age
10 and my dad said to me what you do in
school today rod you've learned how to
believe what you learn how to think well
i went up in my room and thought about
that one but then i began a recollecting
where i was taught to believe even if it
was factually inaccurate like we didn't
have a public library we had a memorial
privately endowed library and my teacher
said no it's a public library and i said
no it is and she brought me in the dumb
steer that's teaching to believe we had
a tradition of discipline of course and
there are a lot of ways to discipline
children and if we did something out of
order we were told to stand in the
corner near the sewing machine look at
the wall and ponder our misbehavior and
they very rarely said to us stop it cut
it out do this don't do that they threw
proverbs at us wonderfully appropriate
proverbs which we heard more than once
and because they came from a proverbial
tradition and these proverbs were so
such pearls of wisdom after all they
stood the test of centuries they had a
calming and very discipline effect on us
my on adma in in lebanon
over a thousand proverbs she talked in
Proverbs there wasn't anything we could
tell her about human behavior that she
never proverb fourth and a while back I
said to myself I wonder how many
proverbs I know out of our culture
english-speaking culture and I just
barely made it to 20 and only because of
Ben Franklin and and that I think that's
an impoverishment and are in our in our
country I think books have been written
on the utility of Proverbs the meaning
of Proverbs of course and we can't go
into it now but I think teaching
children proverbs is the way to go in
between Harry Potter books the tradition
of simple enjoyments talking about Harry
Potter we had almost no commercial
entertainment except going to see Yankee
games on the train and one or two movies
of a year at the Strand Theatre it was
gardening hiking bicycling building
puzzles building snow people in the snow
jumping into huge drifts climbing trees
playing kick-the-can in the backyard and
arguing and my father used the most
remarkable utopian schemes in order to
hone our skills and one of them was he
said he always had to wrestle with what
he do about greed and power in human
history that's a eternal problem look at
it today the corporate executives and so
on and he had something he called
limitation of wealth he said we should
have an economic system where you can
achieve unlimited income but if you had
over five million dollars in wealth you
had to give it away charitably or it's
taxed away
now that's that topic was good for 20
years of arguments how would they evade
it what if they gave it to the wrong
charity what if this what if their
relatives were involved in the charity
how is it going to be administered a
just loved it because it really it kept
us going ever higher levels of
intellectual inquiry as we were great
school high school college and and so on
we had a tradition of independent
thinking and this one started in a very
memorable way third grade came home was
whining crying mom I want to wear long
pants the other boys are wearing long
pants why do you want to wear long pants
well it's cold in the winter and if I
fell I wouldn't scrape my knee didn't
work tried my tongue trump card mother
strained up mother their mothers let
them wear long pants mother looked to me
smiled and said well well they have
their mothers and you've got yours
and then the trump card she said why are
you worried about being a little
different why are you worried about
being a little different one day my dad
said jump into the car Ralph I'm going
to take a tour around Winston my mother
had written an article how to tour your
own hometown because you know people
live in home time they don't ever visit
the factory is the drinking water
purification plant whether lack of
curiosity or just keep deferring them
and so we we went past the library and
it was private philanthropy miss
Beardsley $10,000 donation 1,900 went up
to he'll to the first County Hospital
two families donated the money who built
it in 1901 went over to the high school
was built by an industrialist the owner
of the Gilbert clock company in town
which is a world-famous clock at the
time went by a park same thing
philanthropist set it up went by the
orphanage on a very nice orphanage ship
is also local industrialist then we
stopped by the curve of the house and
just was quiet for a few minutes and he
said you know there are at least 100
families in this town during this period
her as wealthy or wealthier than these
people imagine what this town would be
like they did the same thing that is
they established institutions and he
never let government off the hook in
terms of their responsibilities of
course but he didn't want to let the
wealthy off the hook and he practiced
what he preached to the extent of his
resources always was very charitable fed
people who were in a depression walked
into his restaurant the restaurant was
huge sprawling place on main street
opposite textile mills and hundreds of
workers would come and tourists and
civil jurors on a lunch break and
lawyers and doctors and trades people
and painters and carpenters and
teenagers it was a bustling place of
argument bantering jokes ethnic jokes
which today would be ah you know
politically incorrect but they were
ethnic jokes in front of
each other the Italians would have
ethnic jokes with the Polish Americans
and the Irish would have nicole's with
the Jewish Americans it didn't it wasn't
suppressed it was in a way of relieving
tensions and I remember once I dentist
who rented the place of love my dad's
restaurant to my dad who owned the
building and he was drafted into the
army over 15 million people in the army
that World War two they needed Dennis
and so he's drafted he's made a captain
and he came down is rather worried about
what would happen on his return my
father says I'm not renting that space
so when you come back from the Army you
just come by we'll have a cup of coffee
I'll give you the keys and you upstairs
reopen your practice and you know in
World War two you could rent anything
just like that well to him that was the
family value translated to family
practice business practice rather he
didn't draw a line that way we didn't
draw a line between our civics
involvement our business practice and
and our family practice they had
disagreements and my parents they had
conflicts but not in front of us they
thought we wouldn't understand we
disrespect them so they ironed them out
privately I remember being appalled by
the totally out very very noisy
conflicts between mother and father and
in our town sometimes spilling out into
the street and pots and pans being
thrown after them and the children
watching and crying because our our
parents never did they were pretty low
key anyway they were very involved but
they weren't aggressive about about
things there was a the tradition of work
we have to do our chores and sometimes I
didn't like to do the chores I'd rather
listen to Mel Allen on WI NS New York
Yankees and I it amazed me how fast the
grass grew
and how fast the leaves fell in the
autumn and how fast the snow piled up
but when I heard those steps my mother
heading toward the living room I knew I
had to turn turn to turn off even if it
was the ninth inning with the bases
loaded and a one-run lead the tradition
of business was a great education for us
we had to meet a lot of people fast in
in the restaurant we had to interact
with him we had to read them and
watching my father operate it was really
tough I mean a restaurant is all he was
open to seven days a week he had bulging
veins in his feet and legs because he
had to stand so much you had to worry
about food coming on time the cook
showing up the supplies the quality the
people came in and arrest of all kinds
of temperament some had a bad day and
they're very impatient and coffee had to
be fresh and often the heat didn't work
and the the restaurant was destroyed
three times by the flood of the Mad
River over flooding its banks and
destroying Main Street but he still had
an equanimity to him he's very upbeat he
hated to regret and one day for
teenagers were in the booth I never
misbehaving and they were pouring pepper
into the Sugar Bowl you can't use sugar
on your pepper in a sugar bowl so my
father saw this he walks over leans on
the table looks him in the eye and says
why are you insulting your parents then
he then he gradually took the bowl away
didn't ask him to leave just let him
think about what they did so he was very
much into deep imprint not just showing
anger and get out of here very much into
deep imprint and my mother really tired
of the floods they took lines and
destroyed property
the town always procrastinated doing
anything about it the solution was clear
was a dry Dan north of the Mad River so
the water would back up and dry damn is
not all that expensive so she took
matters into her own hand one day she
heard that senator Prescott Bush was
coming to town campaigning he's the
grandfather of the president we have had
to observe three generation of bushes
and there has been a distinct
contemplation a decline in contemplative
ability clearly over three years had to
do to engage in some dramatic
understatement about the present
commander in chief so she stood in line
and she finally reached him and the
receiving line he was shaking hands
shake hands smiling shaking hands my and
she shook his hand and she said senator
bush we've got to get her dry dan you've
got influence in Washington get the
corps of engineers to build it anything
like you know next hand she wouldn't let
go she would not let go there are 10
people watching this and he's like going
like this she would not let go until he
said I'll get you that dry damn we gotta
dry damn haven't had a flood sense now
her lesson to us was about the only time
you're going to get close to a
politician is to shake the politicians
hand and if you want an answer to your
question don't let go
there's three more traditions one
tradition of patriotism not what you
might think it was not flag waving my
father could not wait for anybody in a
restaurant to question his patriotism
loveitorleaveit go back where you came
from like it made his day he'd have
responses like this you know mr. Nader
if you keep talking spouting off like
this you're going to lose business he
said really I've already lost business
but when i sailed past the statute of
liberty 1912 i took it seriously don't
you and then he turns the table by the
way fellas do you love your country draw
and write we do well then why don't you
spend a little more time improving it
that's the way he dealt with patriotism
it meant improving your community and
your country and your your people and
your neighbors that's what patriotism
that's what was drilled into us at a
very very young
and
and when others through these symbols
Adam the flag the star-spangled banner
took the pledge of allegiance he'd had
more of a ball when they threw the
Pledge of Allegiance I bet you you never
said the Pledge of Allegiance I said
really he said well I happen to know the
last few words of the pledge of
allegiance to you and he'd think of it
because you know they pledged allegiance
of school and then they didn't want to
repeat it and he forced him to he says
what is the Pledge of Allegiance ND and
they say with liberty and justice for
all he says right not liberty and
justice for a few liberty and justice
for all and who's going to get it if
it's not we the people they had a look
he loved the restaurant because he loved
to talk like that they'd say for a
nickel you got a cup of coffee in nato's
restaurant 10 minutes of politics
tradition of Solitude they let us be by
ourselves not over schedule as today's
words have it so we gazed at the stars
and rushed to the meadows and did our
puzzles just you know just by ourselves
my mother said to my sister I'm not
going to let you join the high school
choir unless you learn how to sing by
yourself first then you join the choir
she had a great way of teaching us that
some things were priceless a word much
abuse now by MasterCard
afternoon beautiful spring day backyard
all children there at the parents and my
mother says how much is a dozen eggs
what's the loaf of bread cause what
about a pound of butter five pounds of
potatoes and we know the answer is
wonder what's going on here were arrest
or a family you know why are you asking
these questions she paused and smiled
today what's what's that sunshine worth
nice cool breeze how many dollars look
at those birds singing in beautiful
songs what's that cause and our apple
tree how much does that cost to buy we
got the message after a while there are
certain things that are very valuable
that you can't put a price on and just
because you can't put a price on it just
because they're not for sale that
doesn't mean they're not valuable and
later on I translated this into
describing things in our democratic
society that should never be for sale
that are for sale election should never
be for sale politicians should never be
for sale teachers should never be for
sale and childhood should never be for
sale so when people
people say I where did I come from I had
a lucky choice parents a lot of children
have lucky choice of parents a lot of
parents are very good parents a lot of
parents are too busy to write down and
transfer and discuss and be
self-conscious about traditions and
their family going back generations and
we have a little website just to get the
ball rolling inviting people to send us
there to their favorite traditions it's
17 traditions calm is the website in the
last tradition as you might guess was a
tradition of civics and my mother and
father taught us by example they were on
the phone with the newspaper editor they
were at meetings they were always trying
to work on nagging town problems like
the lack of parking which was hurting
Main Street business or the school's
needed repair once after the flood the
children of the town didn't have
anything to play with so my mother
organized a a section of the YMCA so
they could play there instead of just
have to walk down the stench in the mud
and the wreckage of the main street and
my father was always looking at the
business you know he didn't know it at
the time but he he really in a small way
expressed Alfred North Whitehead 'he's a
very memorable description years ago
when he said a society is great when
business thinks greatly of its functions
and i just like to end with reading a
short passage here and at the end of
this book it's a short book shortest
book I ever wrote and it starts out
children develop their notions of
fairness at a very early age in their
innocence they're often able to imagine
a world without poverty war or
pollution far more easily than their
elders they have no axe to grind which
gives them a wonderful clarity and
Optimus optimism through their words
deeds and traditions my family gave me
the gift of believing in such ideals
their strengths were my metabolism they
propelled me to try to reach as many
people as I could and to try to show
them that most of our problems had
solutions if only people would give
themselves enough time to stand up and
be counted and if only some of us would
stand tall and lead for the people do
have the power but only if they
recognize it and then take the time to
apply it that is the biggest if in
politics isn't it but that is the best
reason for trying to make the flowers of
democracy bloom there's an ancient
Chinese proverb whose words I carry with
me everywhere I go one that captures the
spirit of my parents legacy quote to
know and not to do is not to know to
know and not to do is not to know end
quote thank you very much
ralph nader on his childhood memoir the
17 traditions learn more about the
consumer advocate and three-time
presidential candidate at nader org